hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about noticing in language
learning now I have said before that I
think there are three key elements in
language learning and I was quoting the
head of the language department at the
University of art was at the San Diego
State University who said that language
learning comes down to attitude time
with the language not necessarily time
in the classroom but time with the
language and the ability to notice and I
think most people understand that you
have to have a positive attitude you
have to like the language you have to
feel that you know you're confident that
you can learn the language like the
language confident of the method you're
using is good
so attitude is important time it takes
time to learn language you have to find
the time you have to you know find an
hour a day to listen as I do and so
forth but then the final one is
sometimes more difficult to explain or
describe in other words how do we
develop this ability to notice what's
happening in the language I mean we're
all aware of the sort of phenomenon that
lots of things go by us we don't notice
things and if we notice something that a
certain brand of car has a certain
feature or something else all of a
sudden we start to notice that
everywhere so that noticing something
once helps us to notice it in other
situations it's part of the sort of
acquiring of knowledge or experience and
I think it applies very much in language
learning
but and I notice myself that you know
certain things in a language that I'm
learning certain structures for a long
time or even certain elements of
pronunciation for a long time I don't
notice them then all of a sudden I start
to notice them and once I notice them in
one place say in a text that I'm reading
then I'll notice it when I listen and by
notice again in different places
eventually it starts to become part of
this new language habit that I'm
acquiring for a new language so what are
the things that help me to notice
alright
I have found that our highlighting in
link when I read on the lesson page
helps me to notice because if I see a
word that's highlighted in blue well
first of all I noticed that this is a
new word for me because I could possibly
read past that and not really notice
that this is a word that I haven't come
across before and then if I save that
word it now becomes yellow and I see the
meaning in one of the dictionaries that
I've chosen to use it linked so now it's
a yellow word but then the next time
that word shows up in a text it's now
highlighted in yellow which reminds me
that I've seen the word before because
actually in most many cases I don't even
realize that I've seen that word before
so having it highlighted helps me to
notice it similarly if I highlight a
phrase because it contains a say tense
or it contains a certain case of a noun
or an adjective I highlight it it also
forces me to notice when I see that same
phrase highlighted in yellow somewhere
else
it helps me to notice not immediately I
might then forget that but then I hear
it somewhere else or I see it again so
every time that my attention is
attracted to this word or structure it
increases the likelihood that I will
actually notice it and notice it again
and eventually learn it another thing
that I have found greatly increases my
ability to notice is listening to our
many stories because in the many stories
which I I have listened to 20 30 40
times not all at once
in other words I go lesson 1 lesson 2
lesson 3 up to lesson 10 then I go back
to lesson 1 I mean it's important to
keep these things kind of refreshing
otherwise you know the brain stops
learning it but I find that the 10th
time that I listen to this story which I
already know I know it's in the story so
I'm focusing more on the words and
phrases and I notice things I notice
words I noticed different forms of a
verb I noticed certain structures which
I didn't notice
for and so that the repetitive listening
to say a story where I'm no longer sort
of focusing on what's gonna happen in
the story but I'm focusing on the
language this helps me to notice so
another thing of course is you know I
have to want to notice I have to want to
notice I'm not just you know taking in
noise I'm actually motivated to wanna
notice words and structures in the
language I want my brain to create some
new you know patterns so that I can you
know get these new language habits so
that eventually I can use the language
so I'm motivated to acquire new habits
I'm motivated to notice the other thing
of course that helps you to notice is
the more you read and listen then there
are more and more things that you
already know so therefore just as say
with a jigsaw puzzle then the things
that you don't know stand out so you
have a better chance of noticing these
things because they stand out as being
you know things that you don't know
because all the other stuff is known if
everything is new there's a lot of stuff
that goes by you that you just don't
notice so in a way language acquisition
is a process of noticing more and more
things and as you notice them they
gradually become part of a new language
habit which you have to acquire in order
to become not only someone who
understands the language but also
someone who can speak the language so
just some thoughts on noticing as an
important part of language acquisition
thank you for listening bye for now
you